l'entente beaucoup de théories autour
des vraies raisons de la guerre en
ukraine sur les réseaux sociaux est ce
qu'il ya un complot cachée de l'otan par
exemple
[Musique]
bonjour thomas bonjour fade j'ai entendu
dire que l'otan est le véritable
agresseur dans cette guerre la guerre en
ukraine c'est une aubaine pour les
conspirationnistes qui comme d'habitude
cherchent un sens caché aux choses et
poutine bien ils en profitent en ce qui
concerne l'otan il prétend depuis des
années qu en 1991 un document a été
signé qui garantissait que l'ukraine
n'entrerait pas dans le temps or ce
document n'existe pas alors pourquoi
poutine parle-t-il de nazis et même de
génocide tout est complètement faux
alors présenté comme ça c'est faux
l'accusation de génocide qui concerne la
région du donbass ou des ukrainiens et
des pro russe s'affrontent c'est un
prétexte il y à bien des affrontements
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec un projet
planifié de massacre de la population
les morts se comptent d'ailleurs dans
les deux camps quant aux nazis qui
serait emparé du pouvoir en ukraine
c'est aussi un mensonge
l'ukraine contrairement à la russie
c'est une démocratie l'extrême droite il
fait des scores électoraux dérisoire
mais comme toujours il ya une petite
part de vérité dans cette accusation il
y a en ukraine des groupes armés qui
tolère en leur sein des nostalgiques du
nazisme comme le fameux bataillon azoff
dont tu as peut-être entendu parler j'ai
entendu dire qu'il y aurait des
laboratoires biologique américain en
ukraine dont le but serait d'élaborer
des armes chimiques pour attaquer la
russie on dit même que le colis 19
pourrait provenir de ses laboratoires et
qu'il s'agit d'un plan de l'otan pour
déstabiliser le monde et bâtir un nouvel
ordre mondial selon les complotistes le
nouvel ordre mondial c'est un projet
diabolique visant à instaurer une
dictature universelle c'est juste un
fantasme il faut le dire clairement
concernant les laboratoires il y en a en
ukraine
comme dans beaucoup d'autres pays et les
états unis financent des installations
de recherche destiné au contraire à
réduire les menaces biologiques la
russie explique depuis qu'elle a
commencé à envahir l'ukraine qu'en fait
le coc vide a été fabriquée en ukraine
puis envoyé en chine
évidemment pas la moindre preuve de cela
mais la propagande poutinienne n'a aucun
scrupule à mentir ouvertement d'autres
disent que la guerre après la pandémie
est une autre façon de nous contrôler on
nous en craindre un conflit nucléaire
cela supposerait que poutine et le reste
du monde sont complices pour installer
une dictature mondiale pourquoi alors le
monde entier multiplierait les sanctions
contre la russie c'est pas logique et en
fait c'est surtout pas très sérieux
certains médias russes comme rte ou
spoutnik ont été interdits d'accès en
france certains disent que les pouvoirs
européens veulent nous cacher la vérité
en supprimant ses contenus ce ne serait
pas mieux d'avoir les infos des deux
côtés au contraire les contenus diffusés
par ces deux médias sont très tournée
vers le complotisme et la désinformation
il est arrivé par exemple qu'on explique
que les attentats commis ces dernières
années en france et bien été le fait de
notre propre gouvernement ou que les
vaccins étaient dangereux sans parler du
fait qu'il donnait la parole à de très
nombreux complotistes mais que répondre
à ceux qui voient dans cette guerre un
piège tendu par l'otan à poutine d'un
point de vue de la stricte sécurité des
frontières russes l'otan n'a jamais
menacé la russie c'est pour poutine une
manière de retourner l'opinion en se
faisant passer pour une victime du
méchant au clos sam tout cela pour
justifier d'attaquer un pays voisin
[Musique]